foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
our good buddy Brian Cranston called in
last week and uh said I want to give
away Super Bowl tickets Big Brothers Big
Sisters will benefit every penny raised
will go to Big Brother's big sister and
the great donation there only five
dollars and you were able to donate it
Brian Cranston big game.com we loved the
opportunity to be a part of this and
Brian has joined us a couple times and
as we draw interest to that now it's
time to do the drawing uh Brian before
we get to the drawing if you wanted to
go to the Lakers game last night being a
big time Celebrity Big Time actor how do
you go about getting tickets to
something like that
well first of all I'm trying to get out
of this dark room
quite a while wait are you there with
Aaron Rodgers
[Music]
thank you thank you I have decided to
become the starting quarterback for the
Green Bay Packers okay although there is
zero demand for me to do that
um what did you learn about yourself in
that dark place
I I'm scared of the dog I don't I don't
like it
um
uh you know we're celebrating here in
Los Angeles it's a big night for us to
have LeBron uh take over the scoring
title it's
do you think that that record will ever
be broken wait a minute wait a minute
he'll go for could you have gotten into
the game last night and if so how does
that how do you go about getting tickets
you know Dan I'm a big shot celebrity if
I made one phone call
I would hope that that phone call would
lead to another and then to another yes
and then possibly I'd yes I can get a
ride to this to the the arena okay and
stand out and buy some scalp tickets
yeah I could do it okay but if you got
tickets but they didn't put you in the
front row they put you in like row nine
nine is good okay
single digit No I um no I'm not gonna be
on the floor
um I was recently on the floor at a
Houston Rockets game
wait you were playing I think you could
have played I I wasn't playing I was
tempted but you know it's it's so much
fun to see it from that perspective I
was the uh I was the guest of the of the
owner oh nice yeah uh the best and it
was it was great have you acted with an
athlete before
I
um
let's see I I do remember one thing no I
don't think I have but I remember being
offered a role
about
seven years ago or so when they said
um this is this role for this movie but
the the other role that they're going to
for the the He-man kind of character is
uh O.J Simpson oh I said really
really you're gonna you're going there
and then then even before I could answer
they were going yeah maybe not but let's
let's reconsider everything and it's
like okay
um no I I I haven't
um
I I'd like to that'd be fun man
what if uh let's say an athlete asked
you for a tip on acting can you give
them like a cliff notes version of what
to do
yes
you know the I I could I have to assess
if they had any Talent first you know
and then and then because you can't you
can't teach it it's like it's like NBA
players or NFL players they have an
innate talent that can be coached to
become really good but if it's not there
foundationally there's nothing you could
do you can't teach Talent so you can
encourage it and and and pull it out of
them but it's got to be there by the way
the second season of uh your honor
yeah but no you're really well you
weren't going to do the second season
remember you scolded me because I gave
away the ending for season one and you
said there's nothing to do for season
two and then all of a sudden I say
season two is coming out would you like
to use this moment to apologize
I would like to I I fair enough I I did
unfairly scold you yeah and then I went
to another dark room and contemplated
things I couldn't find anything by the
way it's dark all right okay all right
and then I came out of it saying yes
let's do a second season of your honor
and it's doing incredibly well so we're
excited Showtime yeah I brought up
Malcolm in the Middle maybe do something
years later and I'm gonna guess that's
probably gonna happen soon is there
going to be a Malcolm in the Middle
movie or another season what do you got
for me
you're like Nostradamus you're like
you're like
predicting the future
yeah no it's possible Nostradamus is
what it is
Nostradamus yes there it is are you
gonna do something with Malcolm in the
Middle
it's it's quite possible
wait a minute my guys want to give me a
round of applause but don't no no
just helping Brian out no
yes okay it's uh it's possible if we
find if we find a a viable storyline
that we're all excited about then we'll
do it but nobody nobody wants to be
involved in something just to do it it
it's it it would be like you know
bringing back the love boat or something
which is like all right make it make it
important make it make it significant
all right before we do the drawing
Paulie has a bad idea for you yes Paul
yeah this is might be the worst idea
ever you know they do prequels now like
uh Yellowstone a Breaking Bad prequel
where you're just a chemistry teacher
going to work normally every day and
coming home to a normal life your
thoughts
Holly I think you got something there I
don't know and everybody every episode
would be waiting for something to happen
and nothing yeah nothing happens no we
could call it something bad not breaking
bad but maybe something bad
I like it like a stubbed toe or
something you know a hangnail who knows
that's what somebody takes your parking
spot that's the entire plot for you know
an episode there we're waiting for for
Walter White to lose it and then we'll
see signs along the way we're go was
that when he lost was that when he lost
it you go to the hospital the doctor for
the first time and they want to check
you out clean bill of health this time
around something bad something bad with
Brian Cranston I'll take another Victory
lap okay here we go here's the big
drawing this is what uh Brian has been
very generous to give the two tickets to
the game airfare hotel ground
transportation and the minimum donation
was only five dollars and I hope we got
up to two hundred thousand dollars on
this Brian because it was all okay first
yeah first of all no we're it's closed
so as of uh 15 minutes ago uh I think we
had to close it off so nobody can can be
a part of it now but yes you know oh so
close uh the final tally we have is
197 068 that's unbelievable that's great
and it all right all going to big
brothers and big sisters every penny is
going so uh the winner of the contest
who's going to uh gets the rendezvous
with you and I don't know what that
means but uh they get to normally it's a
meme
can you pause for a second yeah no you
can't pause okay the winner is I can
pause I can't even read that I can pause
okay okay here we go you're gonna put
all your glasses here we go big
announcement Brian Christ
big announcement here it is the winner
wait drum roll of the two take it
drumroll
okay
tickets going to the Super Bowl the
winner is
Steve Baldwin of piulup Washington
yeah yeah
Washington yeah
not Stephen
not Stephen Baldwin the actor
I don't think it's Stephen Baldwin the
actor okay uh I don't know that he would
be living in yellow
um but hey Stephen congratulations and
before we go I want Dan yeah you and
Fritz and everybody of the team the
reason that this became a success in
just one week that we this has only been
happening one week is because of your
graciousness and I wanted to thank you
very much for allowing us to come on Big
Brothers Big Sisters is is the
beneficiary of this but it would have
happened if we didn't have the platform
that you have Mike thank you know what
let me I'm just going to ask you guys
right there did that sound sincere
I think it was pretty sincere an eight
like seven yeah
hmm wow well I wasn't yeah you want
another take there ready three okay
three two one
but I want you to to know Dan
that I
I love you and I appreciate everything
you've done
for this for this raffle we just had it
going for
we just had it going for one week
when you do you did us a favor you
really did and the Big Brothers Big
Sisters will be will be very happy to
receive this money it'll go to a good
cause
thank you
wow yeah wow
that's acting it's impressive right
there
you're forming in the left
[Laughter]
was that acting or was that Brian just
being Brian because I think that's just
Brian being Brian
how can you separate the two oh well
yeah
yeah you're right Hey listen though I'm
serious serious thank you thank you for
for putting us up there thank you to the
NFL to PopCorners propeller uh and
especially big brothers and big sisters
of America they're going to get 200 000
that's awesome and
um it's fun it was fun and let's I just
hope it's a great game everybody at full
strength and uh let's have fun thank you
again for letting us have the honor of
Hosting this you've been a great friend
for the show for a long time and safe
travels here and uh thank you again
Brian
appreciate it Dad thanks buddy thanks
guys Brian Cranston one of the great
actors um I think we kind of Unearthed a
few things there we got a prequel to
Breaking Bad called something bad just a
chemistry teacher going to work and
coming home yes nothing else